uh i'm thinking of calling this series
the uh power wash power hour
another person entering the power hour
arena i like it
that's the plan everyone on youtube has
to have a power hour series i know right
yeah
i would love to actually talk about that
because i kind of wanted just to be a
free space to talk about whatever
because i realized that on the last oh i
guess why am i starting i'm just so
addicted i haven't even kicked any of
this off i don't have an intro or
anything i don't know what i'm doing man
it's okay you you got this i believe in
you yeah well everyone welcome this is
the first episode of i think i was
actually gonna call it power wash pals
um but i don't know whatever power wash
power hours sounds so good though power
wash power pals yeah something like that
i like that all right comments uh tell
me which one of those is your favorites
uh my first guest is uh
sean mr jacksepticeye
captain coffee poppy himself captain
coffee the lord of the beans
himself has graced yes with his presence
there you go wow
write something do something cool all
right now that we're together hang on
okay
that's gonna be really cool
no that's wrong
[Laughter]
[Music]
too much of my own artistic ability but
i think they my editors might have to
censor that
i had no idea what you were drawing for
the longest time
i'm not saying it was well drawn but
i appreciate not going for the penis
okay good i thought that was too cliche
that's old us that's like yeah 2014 us
right the bar was so low yeah and we
still found a way to get under it
[Music]
you know me always plumbing new depths
yeah uh well uh everyone watching at
home this is uh just a chill opportunity
for uh people to power wash because it's
such a simplistic thing and chat about
those things that we ordinarily do not
chat about or whatever have you this is
yeah it's basically a way for you to
feel better about your addiction of
playing this game
hey now come on
the prompt you weren't supposed to read
oh [ __ ] i'm off script yeah nah i mean i
was i was playing this the other day and
i really was like man i keep things
really close to the chest a lot and i
just like so many secrets not like not
like bodies in my closet but you know
secret projects that i'm working on or
you know oh i got to keep the mystique
up and it does serve a purpose and there
are some things that i'm like i
shouldn't spoil everything but also just
like an opportunity to talk openly about
whatever
whatever you just have on your mind so
that's kind of all this really is yeah i
did um i did like the trash taste
podcast recently with the anime man and
his crew
and they
and his crew as if he's like the head of
it but
i'm trying to find an entry point for
you to understand uh no i'm i'm on i'm i
gotcha
but um yeah that was the thing i i like
told a story about like how i wanted to
do whiskey before coffee and everyone
was like oh really
did i not talk about this and then
another story about how i got sent like
horseshit to my house one time like
there was a there was a service you can
just send animal [ __ ] to people's houses
as like a prank
and of course
being a youtuber and people finding your
address is like oh
right you can do that and then people
are like i had no idea and i'm like man
the amount of stuff that we've gone
through that people probably just have
no idea about yeah it is really kind of
a mystery this world that we live in not
that we're different people but just
like the circumstances that we uh are in
are
kind of fundamentally different so
there's things that we have to think
about that not a lot of people do um and
not in a oh we're so special in an oh
man kind of way you know yeah i think it
was um
because vidcon just happened recently uh
from this recording maybe not the upload
but um i forget which minecrafter
was talking about this uh i think they
talked about it afterwards um
there was uh someone that said like wow
being at vidcon was great because of all
the people there actually able to see
the fans which i like i do appreciate
and that's great um but he also said
something about
i it made me realize however i was kind
of sad because i couldn't make a
personal connection with my fans and i
was like yes that that that thing i
pointed at i was like that thing
like that's
people know the me crying meme probably
um from my like eight million
subscribers i'm your manny crying video
from my many many crying videos um but
that one in particular was like
particularly sad because i had that same
realization and it was almost like a
culmination of denialism for me being
like no i can maintain this relationship
i can that that video solidified that
feeling of me just like oh [ __ ]
i can't and that was that was really
hard to take yeah i think we all like
have our own version of it at some point
it like hits well weirdly it's like
hitting at the same time because i
remember like i think it was felix that
went through a certain period after like
five or six years and then it was kind
of like like what am i doing what do i
want to do next and then i remember you
going through the same sort of thing
around the same sort of benchmark
and then i was like yeah it won't happen
to me and then almost
the exact same time frame like within
that five to six years i was like what
am i doing man should i quit i think i'm
done yeah i don't know what else to do
yeah man i i think people don't realize
just how many times probably you and i
well me have said to myself is it time
to quit like should i do it uh because
it is one of those things where you
don't want to just fizzle out you don't
want to hold on too long because that's
kind of sad uh you've seen examples of
it i'm not going to name specific ones
but i'm sure people in the comments can
say specific examples of like moments
when they've seen like a content creator
or someone in the internet or a
celebrity or whatever that held on too
tightly trying to
just cling to that last bit of hope uh
it's not even a relevancy thing it's
like you know everyone has their moment
and it ends at some point mineland like
yours will end or maybe like
it won't i have no idea we don't really
know what the future is i thought my
channel would have died a long time ago
but here i suggested
maybe that's where that period kicks in
because it's like [ __ ] i thought i
thought i'd be kicked off this platform
i have been canceled by far i should
have done something shitty by far right
now
well i'm sure we've done stuff that
well i guess not really but
it's a case of i think it's like holding
yourself more accountable than anybody
else can i feel like you and i both kind
of come from maybe that's why like some
of the jadedness kicks in at some point
for some parts of it because it's like
you you
we like to do things honestly and
earnestly and
a bit more transparently
and kind of like
kind of keep our audiences in the loop
and then when you can't it kind of like
falls apart and then
there's just a lot of things that play
with it that kind of gets in your head
um
and some other youtubers just aren't
like that and it's a different like form
of doing this sort of work yeah they're
just
different
yeah
like there's goods and bads for both
because i feel like the people who are a
bit more closed off then don't have
as
much like pressure put on themselves
to like keep that sort of connection but
if you start off with that genuine
uh sincerity and kind of like
having that open door nature and then
that kind of falls apart and then people
are like man it's just not the same as
when you were like able to talk to all
of us i'm like yeah i know and it
[ __ ] sucks
like trying to figure out a way of like
trying to get that communal feeling back
in a system that's full of like bad
comment systems and
bad rating systems like how do i how do
i connect with you guys i know right and
it's like the sad thing is i don't think
that there ever will be a way to do that
humans just weren't built to operate on
such a massive social scale it is
completely un
like it's completely dissimilar from
anything our ancestors ever experienced
the only times that they might have was
when they were some emperor or a king or
something and they all went crazy every
single one of them so yeah it's uh i'm
not saying we're kings or emperors but
it's like when you have that many people
that are willing to forgive you of
anything and like will always adore you
and you always have that core super fan
base uh that that could like really
poison someone's perspective i'm not
saying it hasn't poisoned mine or yours
but i mean it's just like it's it really
is a the adage of like power corrupts
you know yeah i mean that's in some
places it definitely skews your
your perception of people because it
turns into like you just go through so
many experiences where people want
something out of you so then everybody
at some point it's like well what do you
want
you kind of have to like unlearn that
pattern because i keep
i keep reiterating as well everyone
keeps talking about like oh hate is so
like don't believe the haters like do
your own thing and whatever and like
yeah but there's so many people who are
just willing to kiss our asses for doing
nothing mm-hmm
it's like i use the example of like
you or i could go to twitter right now
and say guys having a bad day can you
give me some compliments and then it's
it's easy you just
people immediately tell you how amazing
you are and that's so poisonous to
someone's mind yeah yeah i mean
encouragement is one thing but you're
totally right about that because it is
just that distortion of reality is maybe
you were being a [ __ ] and you don't
need compliments right now like yeah
it's it's a it's just uh creating it's a
confirmation bias you know it's it's uh
an echo chamber of what you want to hear
as opposed to what you need to hear in
the moment um and that's why i operate
on that principle of like i don't really
get bothered by bad comments um but also
i don't really get impacted by good
comments it's it's those comments from
friends and people that i really trust
that cut me to my core um yeah because
they know me or at least i believe that
they should know me so it's like oh [ __ ]
it really makes me look inside myself
and it really makes me feel good when
they do compliment me so it's
it's uh it's a constant trade-off and
now recently vidcon it was different i
went to vidcon for one
panel only i was not there for the whole
event um but i had an interesting
experience because it's now it's now
vidcon presented by tick tock so that is
oh yeah that is a much more fundamental
change i think than people realize in
terms of the landscape of content
creation and like what it means to be a
content creator um but there there was
an interesting moment there with another
content creator there's a couple there
but i personally had one where there was
another creator and i hope he doesn't
think i'm calling him out or anything i
just thought it was really interesting
um from like a social dynamic uh aspect
he came up to me i didn't recognize him
and he said like oh hey you're
markiplier right
uh i have 19 million subscribers and
then he he presented that as like this
is my reasoning of why you should listen
to me and i legitimately laughed i
laughed out loud at the ridiculousness
of it um and i think he thought i was
like laughing at his number of
subscribers or something which i wasn't
i really wasn't i was just like i've
never had anyone introduce himself with
their number of subscribers first
because if it's not evident for people
listening at home i don't care i don't
care how many or few you have if you're
interesting to talk to i'll talk to you
and i have if i have the opportunity to
do so but it was the animator versus
animation guy
which of course i didn't recognize him
um but i was like oh [ __ ] i've watched
your stuff since new grounds like i
watched the first right way back when so
it was it was one of those things where
it's like i don't need to know your your
metrics of success like on the internet
but apparently like that that is the
thing you know people care very much
yeah about how many followers you have
and that ties into my other thing of you
probably saw the the tick tock from the
creator the tick-tock person who
uh didn't have a single person at their
meet-and-greet right oh yeah which is
very sad and i'm sure it's not like they
don't have fans or their fans are fake
that's not what i'm saying at all it is
like uh it's the difficulty of being
like a global
uh platform and a global influencer you
don't know where your audience really is
so even if you have say a million
followers which is an ungodly amount of
people you should be very proud of that
um it doesn't always translate to people
showing up in the moment um and right
additionally there's this disconnect in
terms of connecting to the creator
themselves that i think tick-tock as a
platform doesn't really allow for as
much as
yeah it's not so much a forum anymore
there but it's it's kind of like i mean
it's the same like both of us went on
tour at one point and it's
it's the same thing where it's like how
do i get you guys to come out and see me
in person versus like what i was doing
on a screen and a lot of people are very
active and they they really want to and
youtube is better at pushing that than
tick tock would be but
at the same time you go to the town and
then people are like oh my god why are
you here it's like i've promoted the
[ __ ] out of this
and you still have no idea why i'm in
town
yeah and like i'm such a big fan and i'm
like really i've been talking about this
for like
four months
and i felt like i was saying it too much
and then it's like no clearly clearly
not i need to talk a lot more about this
because i've
always had a hard time kind of tooting
my own horn
i never hype up my own content no matter
what i'm doing i like
i'll talk about it and say that i'm
proud of something that goes well but
i'll never be the one to be like yeah
i'm the greatest look at what i made
it's so good because i'm like if if the
content's good it'll speak for itself
and people who really enjoy it will
enjoy and then they'll say nice things
about it and that means more to me than
i i don't know i feel like these
platforms for a lot for a lot of people
is like you kind of have to tell people
how you want your content to be
perceived and i've always kind of
avoided that because i don't
i'm like if i'm being a shitty person
then i don't want to just say like i'm
not being a shitty person and then
people are like oh yeah true
true
because you see the people do like
charity stuff and then they're there all
they can do is talk about it like
hey and take pictures about it and then
be like look what i did i'm so great
yeah i know and it's like yes some
people should be proud of their
accomplishments and i i think you should
be part of your accomplishments and uh
but it but it is also a thing like when
we're in a world where algorithms
basically dictate what is presented to
people um
that that makes people think that that's
the only
uh method of consumption for people when
in reality
it it removes choice from consumer to
pursue things that they want or what
they don't know they want and can find
the discoverability of the algorithm is
great the using it as a as a basis to
understand the people who are making
your content is
worse and that's why i also operate on
the mentality of like i want to make
things
and i'll promote the things that i
really think people should care about to
some extent but for the most part i
don't really ask people to subscribe i
don't ask people to like
engage with it i see so much of that
because everyone's like basing on
analysis of data and statistics like if
you mention this at this time code it'll
get this much percentage more
engagements like but also if it was
really good content wouldn't they engage
with it anyway because they have it and
like you and so few people embrace that
mentality because it is less
i hate to use the word successful metric
measurably
impactful is what i'll say yeah i mean
both of us kind of tried it at one point
to see if it would work and i think
we're so ingrained in the culture of
like not doing that that it i don't
think it makes a huge difference for us
yeah but it's it's that youtube is
definitely more of a
a game than an art form at this point
like people aren't creating for the sake
of creating well i shouldn't say
everybody like of course there are
people out there doing it but the things
that people are being pushed in people's
faces all the time
are not that kind of content it's kind
of just it's like it's people
understanding their metrics and then
like fine-tooth combing that and like
dotting the eyes and crossing the t's
and making sure everything's perfect and
it's title and thumbnail first or it's
like so much more paramount to the
content than it's ever been
and then the video goes out whereas i
think you and i
operate on a different kind of basis
where we just we just do things for the
sake of it and i feel like
that's where some of the like maybe i
should quit because it's like i don't
know if i even like this ecosystem
anymore like i just want to make what i
make
and i think that that fundamental like
understanding is where my shift happened
where i'm like yeah i could just ignore
that and do whatever i want and that's
kind of the space that i'm in now where
everything's a bit more fun that way
which is great like i'm super glad to
hear that and i want people at home to
also know because they're probably so
used to hearing people to their own
horns we're not saying we're better than
others for not doing that like yeah
playing your game so it was so much more
noble like it's not what it is if
anything it's it's smart business to
play it that way oh absolutely that's
how you grow yeah clearly there's
measurable success for it and yes it
does work but i always embrace the idea
that there are people behind the views
behind the numbers behind everything i
actually when i was at vidcon i was
talking with ben rellis at youtube he no
longer works at youtube he actually quit
um but i was talking with him about this
exact thing about the idea that a
creator can thrive not only succeed but
thrive uh without really thinking or
planning towards uh algorithmic success
because
it's people-watching it is people and
i've always had this philosophy that
when someone is engaging with your
contract they are giving you their time
and we all know that time is the most
valuable thing that anybody can have
give or spend even if we waste a lot
more
you know just like this whole thing is
an excuse for me to waste time and wash
some stuff
but
that's a contract right that's a
contract for creators with their
audience and if you're going to make it
worth their time
then i want it to be in their hands to
choose whether or not it's worth their
time to come back i'm gonna keep making
stuff and i'm gonna keep trying to
improve and hopefully that's enticing
enough for people to constantly check in
on me which i think is where the
phenomena of like what are you doing in
this town i haven't heard from you i'm a
big fan they are but you know their time
it gets away from them they they get
busy with other things there's channels
that i love and really really admire
that i haven't watched in a while just
because i haven't had the time or it
hasn't been a priority or i haven't
thought about it it doesn't mean that i
don't care about that creator and that
distinction of caring about the creator
and the creations that they make is i
think the key difference in all of that
you have longevity in your fans because
people have seen your journey and seen
how far you come uh in terms of growing
as a creator and as a person uh whereas
if like tick tock stars i'm not
disparaging them in any way
but you may see one tick tock and be
like that was a really funny tick tock
and you may recognize them on the street
uh but the personal connection is
lacking because you haven't seen their
journey because the algorithm has not
dictated that you should see their
journey you have to pursue that and i'm
not saying there aren't fans that don't
pursue that on tick tock but it's
i i don't know about you but i go
entirely by the for you page on tick
tock i don't ever look into people's
profiles
yeah i don't really follow anybody
because i'm afraid that it it'll like
shift my algorithm too much
i'm just like
i'm locked into that kind of humor then
because i do a lot of like reacting to
tick-tock videos
and then it's like i kind of want to
just like keep things a bit more
free-form and have the algorithm like
dictate what i'm watching yeah but that
i feel like that platform is so
algorithmically driven that it's like
even when people try to have a more
personal connection it just
it's like an uphill battle for them and
it's it's really tricky because there's
some people who are really really
talented on there
and really really good and that that
their platforms are thriving there but
it's
i thought it's kind of like twitch and
youtube are a similar case where it's
especially with live streaming like if
someone live streams on youtube it's
like you get a hundred thousand viewers
but it's not like
a hundred thousand viewers would be the
same on twitch it's like
a hundred thousand viewers on youtube is
like
20 30k on twitch i think
for like the amount of
involvement that that chat has and
what's going on i don't like it's not
really comparable is what i'm trying to
say yeah different audiences different
like practices different habits uh
twitch audiences always much more
engaged in the comments way more engaged
yeah and there's a certain fun to be had
with that uh it's not saying our big fat
youtube numbers aren't really really
cool and all but there is something
about having that core audience that is
hyper focused on you and i think twitch
in a way
kind of does it more when i'm talking
about that that personal engagement with
your creator and it is like your creator
because fans if you want to be a fan
with someone you kind of have to
dedicate your entire focus on one two or
maybe a handful of people because you
are watching their stream for hours like
yeah i'd say it's like twitch in terms
of personal engagement is way up there
because it's a pure live streaming
experience youtube is next because you
can see their vaude history their entire
journey
and if you really like something the
algorithm will constantly throw you more
of that person and then tick tock is
like
as the duration of viewing goes
lower and lower the ability to
personally connect with a single uh user
goes down and down um and then with tick
tock there's so many people that i've
never seen before that pop up on my for
you page for one video and i'm like ah
that's great and then i never see them
again yeah it's very digestible culture
and it's it's a shame because
i mean we've been doing this so long
like you're you just hit 10 years i'll
be hitting 10 years in a couple of
months oh yeah and then
it's like
you see all the cycles that goes through
and what comes and goes and i was
talking about this with like tommy and
them at his show yesterday that
there's so many like
companies that try to invade the space
and everyone's like oh it's going to get
too corporate and
we all kind of like worried about it a
little bit and then the thing that
youtube does best and why it still
stands the test of time and why we're
still here is because that open nature
with the creator is what
like makes it thrive
like you can you can watch netflix you
can watch stranger things and everything
but then you have to go somewhere else
to like chat about it yeah whereas
youtube it's like it's audience and
creator melded together which is good
and bad
but
the reason that the platform exists for
so long and the reason that the creators
still kind of dictate what's going on on
that platform like talk shows came in
tried to like dominate the space and
everyone got worried and it just didn't
go anywhere they kind of like
buckled to what
the creators were doing and they still
they talk like creators on there now
because
that like human connection is still king
above everything else like people want
that people like paste themselves on a
youtube avatar
and people who are in like their teenage
years trying to like find themselves
would relate to what we said and i feel
like our channels were so similar for so
long probably still are
but
people like connect with us and live
vicariously through us and that personal
connection and then some people want to
be you and like share your values and
kind of share your morals and be that
type of person so then they just get so
involved in your
style and in your personality and in
your morals and then
as you like shift and grow so do they
and they're kind of your their opinion
shift your content shifts and then they
either grow with you or they like move
on to somebody else that shares the
values that they have now and i think
that that's what's so fundamental
to what we do
um
and that's what tick tock and like
some platforms kind of lack because it
is so it's meant to be digested and it's
meant to serve you as much content as
possible and not give you the same
person too much on like your for you
page or
it's trying to like mix things up all
the time to keep it fresh and not keep
you locked into one space mm-hmm yeah
they just are terrified of people
getting bored and leaving the platform
gotta keep them in the system which is
what every company does so it's not
really that big of a change um but for
the people listening at home i actually
want to list i want to hear what your
thoughts on this are if you have been
able to make a personal connection in
not in a parasocial way i'm we're not
talking about that but it's like you
feel like you really understand a
creator on tick tock i would love to
hear your thoughts on this like was it
more difficult if you have do you find
yourself more of a youtube person a tick
tock person do you think your
consumption is changing of content uh
and again i'm not asking this for
research purposes i'm just generally
curious yeah i don't really care if you
do but i do want to hear if it's easier
or harder for you to make that personal
connection because i think the people
that would be listening here would want
that it's like is the platform working
against you to try and have that
connection mm-hmm that's a good point or
or is it like
it are we just oblivious to it because
we don't use the platform that way
because i feel like we're so ingrained
in youtube culture that we just stick to
this
it's yeah it's funny because it's kind
of the opposite of the way i use youtube
whereas youtube i don't do any really of
the recommendations i go straight to
people's channels if i want to see
anything but today is the very opposite
i
literally let the algorithm control my
fate whatever will be will be uh well i
guess
i guess you go to tiktok for a specific
purpose as well you don't
for most people they go there because
they're sitting on the toilet or on the
train or something and you want
to see like a meme
for like five minutes
or however long you want to waste your
time on it or like you're lying in bed
whereas i feel like
again maybe i'm just totally wrong but
maybe you people go to youtube for a
very different purpose you go there for
like tutorials you go there for updates
you go there for
information kind of stuff i i go there
to sit down and eat a meal and watch
something fun it's the perfect amount of
time for that
yeah yeah really wonderful uh all right
so shifting gears away from internet
culture and our experiences on the
internet yeah we're just sad grumpy old
man
[Laughter]
i mean we don't know what we're talking
about we're not the youth anymore where
everything we said is wrong
i mean everyone watching this is just
like these guys have no [ __ ] idea
what you're talking about
i mean that could be true i've kind of
operated on that principle that i don't
know what i'm talking about half the
time yeah same um but
uh what are things that you are really
getting into hobbies i was talking to
you earlier before this about my new
hobby with electric bicycles and that's
really been consuming my life so uh what
do you enjoy and do in your spare time
now that you are a grumpy old man i've
been trying to find stuff that's not
screen based because we have a room in
our house we call the chill room that's
like there's no tvs or anything in it
there's no screens we kind of don't it's
like our reading room
and i i tried to get into reading for a
while and my adhd brain just
it just wanders far too much
and then i try to
my girlfriend's really into like jigsaw
puzzles
but for me it's like i don't know why i
get into like a challenge with myself to
like do it quickly
and then i can't like find where the
piece is going to go and then i get all
like mad at myself for it like it's not
what you're supposed to be making these
so the thing i've gotten into recently
is just making lego sets ah that's good
it just makes me feel like a big kid
again and it's like it's like 3d puzzles
in a way but i i like the autonomy of it
where i can like i can listen to an
audio book and then
sort of like follow the instructions so
my brain
i it lets my brain melt in a way that's
like really therapeutic for me that i
think doing something with my hands is
very important to me that's not
screen based because a lot of my spare
time is like i like watching movies i
love playing games still in my spare
time but that's
it's like that's still work kind of in a
way but you're well not work but like
you're still sitting at a screen and
you're like you're occupying your brain
in the same sort of space i'm like
trying to find ways to not do that it's
exactly why i like playing this game
it's not quite working with my hands but
it gives that fast simile of it um but
with my hobby of uh doing e-bikes i have
noticed that i have started actually
using my tools and fiddling with the
bike and i keep going yeah i keep going
out to my garage and i'm like
i'm a mechanic
i'm a big boy now i'm using my tools and
then i realized i'm 33 and this is
actually just what i'm doing
yeah but it's been really fun because
that feeling of like being a kid again
um like getting on a bike because i
think almost everybody has at some point
learned how to ride a bike they've
ridden a bike or whatever have you if
you haven't ridden a bike let me know in
the comments i'm so sorry for bringing
this up um but being on an e-bike is
like it's just so fun because you get
that boost of power you know as a kid
you're tireless you know you can never
get tired boundless energy as a grumpy
adult you're like
i don't want to wake up ever and then
you have to get on with your day and do
whatever you're doing um but i commuted
to the corridor office which i'm
interning at for the time being um very
fun by the way i can talk about that in
a bit but it's just like it's just that
little bit of something where i have an
actual hobby that's physical not in any
way digital it's a physical object that
moves me in the world and really grounds
me and connects me it's a cool piece of
technology which is also something that
interests me and i can fiddle with it
and i can also break it which i did this
morning i just completely
abort my entire uh
uh chain tensioner which you know i had
it perfect and then i screwed too hard
and it uh threaded de-threaded this it
stripped the screw and uh it no work no
more so now it's got zip ties on it and
it kind of works
you're gonna get killed on this thing
not probably not but you know it is
that's why i got a full face helmet like
where are your helmets kids people think
it like
you know helmet nerd and i'm like i like
my brain being inside my skull and i
like my chin being intact so i have a
full face helmet and also yeah it looks
super rad dude people were like
do you want to do like creator clash and
box someone and i was like not really
because i already have like tinnitus and
i have like eye issues and i'm like on
the off chance that someone punches me
and then like
something breaks inside my head i'm like
i care about my brain way too much yeah
really people kept thinking like you
know oh your mark's definitely going to
do it next time definitely i'm like
there's i i don't want to get punched in
the head like yeah i'll get pepper
straight because i know that's not going
to be permanent damage like i'm not
going to just go out there and go
jumping off of [ __ ] because i think that
i love the rush so much no i like the
challenge but it's it's
boxing is dangerous that's what people
don't seem to ever really connect with
it's really dangerous getting hit in the
head once can do permanent damage that's
not an exaggeration people need to
understand that i mean plenty of boxers
go through it and they you know they
train and they're able to take punches
and roll with them and be able to handle
themselves in a safe way that's but
that's why amateur boxing can be more
dangerous because they don't know how to
properly defend themselves at all times
and they don't
they're unable to get themselves out of
dangerous situations so they don't
realize that they're putting themselves
in danger and not protecting themselves
there's a lot of variables in there with
amateur boxing that being said i i am
very proud of everyone that did create a
clash i thought it was a great event uh
yeah a huge response to them
absolutely but i'm not gonna get punched
in the head no thank you yeah people
were like would you fight mark and i'm
like
he would [ __ ] kill me
i was like i've seen you rock climb and
you're like
so much beefier than i am i'm like he
would just punch me once in the head and
i would die was it what's your weight at
wha what weight class would you be
um i think i'm down to like 65 or 66
kilos so it's like what is that a lot of
those bizarre numbers what is 65 kilos
in pounds
143 okay yeah i'm 185 right now so i
would have about 40 pounds on you uh and
that makes a huge difference everybody
however my head's also huge and i think
that's a disadvantage because i don't
think it's all skull uh i think it might
just be my brain is big but you know not
in a smart way in an easily bruised way
you know yeah there's a lot more to
rattle around yeah i think that if you
put
if you punch me in the head it'd be like
the pear wiggler and you would my brain
would just
yeah i mean i feel like i could throw a
pretty hefty punch but again
i i just don't want to i don't i also
don't have that thing in me where i need
to find out i don't i have nothing to
prove
i i see that a lot where people are like
oh like you used to try harder or
something like whatever like it's water
off it just back at this point but i'm
like a lot of it is just like like
you're older you're more secure in
yourself i don't need to like prove
myself to many people anymore i'm just
comfy where i am yeah i don't need i
don't need to get punched yeah
absolutely and and a lot of people have
this like uh and there's a better word
than machismo you know a more general
natural term but it's like they have
this desire to prove themselves and be
like i i don't want to be a wimp it's
why people go like oh i don't want to
wear a helmet because that's what babies
do
it's just like at least for really
stupid decisions like that um because
if you fall off anything a bike or
whatever have you uh and you hit your
head uh you could die uh you could just
straight up die not even just like oh
brain damage your death that could
happen brains are very fragile and i
don't mean to be this overly cautious uh
guy but at the same time
definitely just protect yourselves out
there like wear the proper safety
equipment put some stickers on it make
it look cool but just wear it yeah just
like
put a condom on anywhere you go
wear your diaphragm anywhere you go
like you never know when life's going to
come at your heart
put a helmet on your knees god are dive
ribs even really a thing maybe uh maybe
i'm out of the loop but i i yeah i
never met a single person in real life
that uses a diaphragm not that that
comes up in conversation a lot so i
maybe it may be like i don't think i've
ever had a vidcon conversation how many
subs you have it's like i have my
diaphragm on i had when i was in
corridor they were like the power went
out for a moment so everyone was like
just sitting around and uh you know they
were like man it's real quiet in here
without all the computers off kind of
awkward and i was like i have an
icebreaker question that i think uh i
think either matt or ryan brought up at
first it was like have you ever tried to
look at your own butthole in the mirror
uh
the ranges of responses are always
hilarious uh because it's always like uh
well technically i've never done that
like what do you mean technically you've
never done that
yeah that's a very yes or no question
because i've never done that i have
never tried in any way to look at my own
butthole in the mirror since that
conversation brought up but i've been so
tempted when i like if i occasionally
i'm in the bathroom and i'll remember
that that's that that's a question that
people ask and i look at myself in the
mirror like do i want this knowledge
unlocked do i really want to expose
myself to myself
i've stared right down the barrel of
that brown starfish
like i don't think it's going to be a
life-changing situation but it's it's
it's quite the icebreaker in situations
because people just
it's good to know in case you need to
pick your own ass out of a lineup
yes officer that's mine
nah you can exonerate me i didn't do
it well i
okay i don't know how uh you know what
the reason for this is to be like open
honest things we've never talked about
before
i have a very hairy ass that's fine
that's fine so i feel like just for like
good hygiene's sake i need to like shave
my like my innards down there not like
the actual cheeks because who gives a
[ __ ] even though
as a kid it gives me horrible insecurity
because every time i saw an ass on tv or
in a movie i'm like why is there no hair
on any of these dudes asses yeah um
it turns out most people are not born in
a bog and are like swamp people like i
am no no no me i'm a glorious hairless
man naturally shiny and smooth
aerodynamic some might say it's just a
marble statue in human form pretty much
you've seen the video yes yes it has
turned out oh yeah greek god yes of
course
i've been around you many times you
you love taking your shirt off at any
opportunity
yeah not as much anymore i'm a little
out of shape but i'm getting back with
my personal trainer so hopefully that
yeah me too
i'm like
i want to get like progress quick
because i know i can and have in the
past but i'm like i want to i want to
have like sustainable fitness it's like
kind of like eating
kind of whatever i want like still being
mindful of it but not like oh god i need
to calorie track every single day
because it's just it's kind of miserable
yeah that's why i love the electric bike
because it's not as much of an workout
as you would get if you uh were say just
biking no power um but at the same time
i want to go fast so i pedal harder and
i still have to like make climbs and i
still have to work at it um and i end up
going out on my bike much more than i
would like if i need to go the grocery
store like that's four miles away i'll
take my bike any day i can actually get
there faster on my bike than i would in
my car i have more fun i burn like a
hundred calories or so and i i just
enjoy myself i it's like a fun trip uh
and yeah oh my god you just jump-scared
me
and uh and it's it's that little little
extra push is like oh my god this is
like recess for kids you know i just
like i actually get up and i go out and
do something and it's uh it's that
little bit extra and i think that's
helping me in a lot of ways from because
you and me we record videos sitting in a
chair most of the time i can convince
myself i'm being healthy and like i'll
stand today and my standing desk and
just so much better but it's like that
does barely anything yeah i i remember
when i was like the tdee calculators for
like how many calories you're burning in
a day right just by like sitting around
and how many you're supposed to cut in
bulk and whatever i would like train
three times a week and i would put my
thing into that and i was always like
yeah i'm active i train all the time and
then i was like wait no i sit for like
90 of the rest of that time so i was
like i realized that like i think i've i
think i'm considered lethargic in those
kind of apps oh no lethargic like
yeah that was like the realization to be
like man i really need to like get out
and move more
i could not recommend an e-bike more it
is so fun i do kind of think
okay this is me getting you know
mark's big ideas i think that electric
bikes are the future of
same
personality
no there's but there's good reason do
you do you see why do you see
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it keep going
with electric bikes like people have
long known that bicycles are a much more
uh efficient and you know good for the
environment way of transportation
gets people exercise yada yada they're
they're
boring you have to wear your aerodynamic
spacesuit your really dorky helmet yes
there are dorky helmets i said it and
then you look like a big old biker or a
skinny bike whatever you do you look
like a bicyclist you know one of those
people
yeah god forbid yeah
i'm sorry to anybody that really loves
biking i know they don't like e-bikes
very much
but i'm perpetuating the stereotype but
at the same time you're like a crypto
bro for cyclists right now
but the thing that what i'm trying to
say is like there's a barrier to entry
to be good at cycling to get anywhere
with any kind of efficiency speed you
are you have to be good at it you have
to suit up for it you have to account
for sweat all these different things you
can't carry much with you because you
don't have a lot of power e-biking
unlocks the ability to carry stuff with
you
go farther uh for the same like
environmental benefits gasoline benefits
yummy stuff to charge it up and that
costs money but but
all the other benefits of bicycling uh
without having that barrier to entry and
barrier to entry is the biggest
inhibitor of people getting into
something let's say bicycling
by cycling if people like people think
that electric cars are the next
revolution and they're kind of right in
the world where the future is nothing
but cars cars are a plague on society
they are literally the worst invention
except for all the wonderful things that
they've done for the industrial
revolution and all that stuff and really
speeding up you may as a whole but
e-bikes yeah shout out to troy
yeah exactly but at the same time is
like the amount of infrastructure you
need to support a city that runs on cars
which is every city on earth pretty much
except for a few european cities that
are really bike friendly uh it's so much
more space per person than
than you would ever need with bicycles
uh if you do a size comparison to the
amount of people getting through a
street uh on cars versus bicycles the
number is astronomically higher for
bicycles if even 10 of the population
was riding bicycles traffic itself for
those that like cars would almost go
away i don't know if that statistic is
entirely true anymore i heard that a
long time ago i may be quoting that
wrong but it's a it's a certain
percentage and traffic gets better
because less people in cars yeah i mean
i'm dating a dutch person and
it's nothing but bikes there like as
stereotypical and mimi as that is
it's astonishing whenever you're there
it's so fun to cycle in the netherlands
where like the cycle paths are
everywhere if you're actually on the
street cyclists have
more right of way than the on than the
cars that go by they have to like wait
they're not allowed like fly past you
yeah it's so nice and so many people
like you see like 60 year olds 80 year
olds sometimes out cycling around
and everyone just looks far more free
they go out they go out drinking with
their friends or they go out for dinner
and then everyone just hops on their
bikes and go home
it's so cool it's so cool and what
e-bikes do is they lower the barrier to
entry because a lot of people are like
i'm afraid to ride my bike in america
let's say
because of the cars and the traffic and
whatever have you and i was too i i had
that feeling i was like oh i got to be
really careful about what i do and you
do i'm not saying you don't um but the
difference with an e-bike is i made a
16-mile journey uh yesterday both ways
so total i i rode 32 miles uh on my
e-bike um
and it's not like i want to do that
every day because it took me like total
riding was like an hour and a half hour
40 minutes but i did it and i did it
safely and effectively because my bike
my average speed on my bike was 22 miles
an hour like i only
i i got there
20 minutes slower than it would have
taken me in my car in ideal conditions
no no traffic jams no sudden shifts in
traffic um and i was on city streets and
what i found is the biggest limiter to
my speed was not other cars it was
traffic lights traffic lights were like
the bane of my system because i'm like i
should be pedaling right now excuse me
but it's wonderful and everyone can do
that
there are there are stories of like
older people here in america that are
only able to get out and active in any
way shape or form because they have an
e-bike because they have that mobility
the extra power there there still is a
safety concern of course because you
know cars are not
you know cars are driven by people and
people are stupid sometimes uh so they
can make stupid mistakes but that's a
risk even if you're in a car uh so when
it comes down to like being in a bicycle
i actually feel kind of safer because
i'm able to control my environment i'm
able to like i have the power to escape
a situation that i don't want to be in
and i have yet to be in a situation like
that um but i could and i i'm always on
the lookout for anyone that's being
stupid on the road and at the same time
i get exercise i'm having fun i'm
enjoying myself it's just such a goddamn
delight
dude i'm convinced
yeah good sales right
i'm gonna
are you sponsored by oh i might be soon
super 73 come on super 73 is not for
everybody but you know for me it's like
those are like the best sponsorships
where it's like dude i use this all the
[ __ ] time anyway and then they're
like do you want to get paid to talk
about it i'm like yes i can do things oh
my god please they might make me a super
custom bike with more range more power
of like oh my goodness
i'm very excited
you'll be able to visit me on an
electric bike soon i mean technically i
could there are competitions for
solar-powered electric bikes cross not
cross-country cross-continental
electric bike competitions where they're
just like they charge in solar and they
just keep going and going and i think
the longest someone's ever gone
continuously is like
nearly seven thousand miles uh holy [ __ ]
yeah without ever having to stop and
plug in
i think i'm pretty sure anyway it's very
cool it's very cool everyone you could
do it
you could be like him you could be like
me you know how cool i am right
you're talking to your audience
everyone's just gonna say yes no they're
not i've primed yeah we know i i
gaslight them so much to try to break
their conditioning to
kissing my ass all the time it'll never
work do you realize how many
channels and instagram accounts and
twitter accounts i see on my feet all
the time that absolute people absolutely
adore you
guys in the comments below say you're
not brainwashed by me and wouldn't
follow me over a cliff if i asked you
say that
say that
tell everyone that i don't brainwash you
uh-huh yeah see the evidence is clear
clear i'm seeing it now
[Laughter]
anyway it's it's just fun i love having
a hobby now and i love being excited
about something you know yeah there's so
many things to be jaded about uh it's
it's just nice to have something to
focus on plus being with the corridor
guys has been a huge boon they've just
been like it's just nice to be in a
environment of creative people for that
creative energy and they they've been so
nice to me because um originally it was
only going to be a month and then i
extended because like oh man i've barely
done anything i also haven't learned any
of unreal which is like my whole point
of being here uh yeah i have so much fun
making videos but they've just been so
sweet they're like man you've really
been such a added energy to the office
really nice having you i'm like oh my
god because you're a lot of sleep
yeah so it's uh yeah this is lovely i
kind of miss i mean i guess covered kind
of messed it up as well but just being
around like creative people all the time
i feel like kind of when we went to
conventions and we were doing stuff like
fairly often you're kind of always in
that space
and like you're always talking to other
people who are creating stuff and who
inspire you and like i haven't really
had that in a long time
i don't really like
go out to conventions like being at like
tommy's live show last night was cool
because it's like oh man it's like gets
and like ethan's live show it's like it
kind of gets the juices flowing again it
does it does i forgot what i'm able to
do
yeah and it's like i you and i we're all
able to do more than we think and you've
got a project coming up and i'm not
going to spoil anything of it but just
like i'm really excited to see that get
off the ground and yeah it's like i do
love those moments when you see
something that someone else makes and
you get that little jolt of inspiration
like oh that was cool i think i could do
that too like that's what makes
creating really fun for me that's what i
chase all the time um and i think like
more people need to be driven with that
feeling as opposed to this kind of
zero-sum mentality of like if i get
something someone else has to lose it or
if someone gets something that they're
taking away from me that's not what this
is it's never been that it's it's much
more collaborative than you would ever
know uh and you would only know that by
collaborating with other people and
working with them so yeah you get out of
it what you put into it i think
which is kind of like why i want to do
uh
this you know just talk more people just
like hang out with more people and get
their perspectives on things because i
know that like you and i are kind of on
the same page about a lot of things but
there's a lot of other creators out
there who have completely different
motivations uh for doing stuff on the
internet making content completely
different ambitions some people do want
to build those like empires of like
corporate magnanimity and you know
that's cool too but
yeah i mean everyone has something to
teach you yeah so that's why i want to
get more voices in
talk to more people out there maybe do
an internship with i don't know some
other content house you know you want to
do an internship for me
uh sure i'll do that i can teach you a
lot of things okay like what unreal
that's what i'm trying to learn
sure i can like
buy unreal and put it on my computer
uh-huh you learn unreal and you teach me
unreal yeah
put a tutorial on for you yeah no no we
should learn together though because
literally i've i've been goofing off
with uh corridor guys so much i have not
learned
anything i really have not yeah it's
i mean it's a lot to
like take on oh sure i uh
i tried to like learn game engines
before and i tried to learn
unreal and i i sat down and watched like
tutorials and did it like piece by piece
and i made like a little map that was
like a kilometer squared and
it was it was fun and like it had like
terrain and water and i'm like oh this
is fun and then i went back to do it
again i'm like i don't remember anything
oops about this like i was just doing it
step by step instead of learning yeah
that's that's what you really need is
just the hands-on you have an idea you
make it yourself and that you remember
it's super tight that's how i got good
with i mean probably youtube with
premiere and photoshop and all that
stuff is just like you need to make a
thumbnail so you make it and then you're
done and you remember how you made that
one because it was frustrating and then
you slowly get better yeah and it's like
you need a specific thing it's like i
need to be able to cut my head off and
put it on a body and then it's like you
can do that that's such a fun statement
photoshop taught me how to cut a head
off mm-hmm
hell is missing on this thing it's if
you tap it's a surface there are like
some tough stains in green there we go
well we're just about wrapped up here
uh and uh this show ends when the last
bit it gets cleaned so um just cuts off
yeah it just cuts off a harsh cut to
black so yeah thank you so much for
joining me on this um cleaning adventure
it's really lovely talking to you about
various different things
anytime have you wanted
you're genuinely one of my favorite
people in the world no and i feel like
despite our
i don't know because people for a while
were like why don't they talk anymore
why don't they play together anymore
like man life gets in the way everybody
has like different things going on
yeah and i feel like
we've both been on like parallel paths
for so many years and every now and then
they like connect and but they're always
kind of like
going in the same places we always kind
of like have the same mentalities on
things and
i don't think there's ever been like
proper bad blood between either of us no
no yeah so for anyone thinking you know
i mean all all human relationships are
interesting and dynamic in a way but no
yeah you're one of my favorite people
too i love seeing the stuff that you
make and i can't wait to help you make
some of the cool projects uh you've got
on the horizon cooking up in that noggin
and uh a big old brain of mine yeah uh
person who finds the last spot wins i
guess where the frick is it i have no
idea it should glow when you hit tab
like there'll be a slight glow to it
yeah i'm
cabin man one of these walls
ah found it
all right looks like i win
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh does it give us stats and who did
more because i think you did
considerable about more than i did uh
you can see the time lapse wow
look at me go look at me go look just
make the video this time lapse and match
our voices to this
that'll be the episode recap
uh yeah thank you very much man this is
great uh everyone listening at home you
know jacksepticeye link is in the
description obviously uh cool stuff in
the future
um and then yeah you should come uh you
should come back to la sometime yeah i
want to i want to come back more just
for like regular visits instead of when
i just have a [ __ ] ton of stuff going on
hell yeah hell yeah can't wait for it
[Music]
you